we're gonna check out some more Strange
Addictions remember we're leading with
empathy first so be understanding my
name is Mark I'm 20 years old and I'm in
a relationship with 15 inflatable
animals my mother really wasn't there
for me
when I was a child first time I hugged
my inflatable whale I actually started
feeling all that love and compassion
could be oxytocin which is one of the
hormones that your body releases when
you're cuddling this is actually why
animal I mean it's a little bit
different obviously but why animal
therapy works quite well especially in
those newly diagnosed with autism
because animals are not judgmental so
you can show an animal affection and pet
them and enjoy their company without
them judging you and there's less risk
there for humans to be hurt so they
enjoy their time with animals that's why
Equine Therapy does quite well emotional
support dogs Etc now he's so dependent
on his Inflatables he can't be separated
from them for more than a day this is
again entering the the realm of what we
categorize a disorder because he can't
be without them so as a result it can
impact his ability to live a fulfilling
life reaching his major Milestones going
to work having relationships Etc if I
could marry Lila I would because I am
that much in love with her but Mark and
Lila haven't taken their relationship to
the next level yet
me and Lila Dragon don't have sex
together
we keep our relationship clean you know
we've talked about objectophilia which
is when someone falls in love with it an
inanimate object or has sexual desire
for inanimate object and there's been
theories as to why this occurs they're
saying there's some pattern with those
who've been diagnosed with autism those
who have these sensory situations where
in feeling certain things there's a
crossover neurologically that when they
see this inflatable dragon that they
also engage their sexual desires not
because they've trained that way but
because the body is made that way the
therapist helped me realize that my
Inflatables are getting me used to more
socializing with them rather than real
people from now on I'm gonna start
spending a little less time each day
with my Inflatables I'll still have my
Inflatables in my life but they're not
going to be the primary part of my life
[Music]
if something's going on mentally where
you you are finding a lot of value in
these Inflatables just taking them away
abruptly can cause more harm and Trauma
because as you can tell this person has
an adverse childhood event I'm actually
curious about his job situation whose
house that is how does he provide for
himself because those are the questions
that you really need to learn about this
person more so than what the diagnosis
is or what his romantic life is with
these animals that's what's going to
tell me who he is as a human and what
impact these Inflatables are having on
his life I'm Amy I'm Becky and we're 45
years old
and we're addicted to being identical
what
addicted to being identical you either
are twins or you're not twins for some
reason it's not being a teeny bit more
weight than me yeah and people would go
like oh you're the big twin you're the
smaller twin and literally from then on
out oh yeah we make the same exact bites
of food under the same sips of drinking
you know I know some sisters and
brothers that are like this but not to
this degree so I feel like they are
closer than what is expected of normal
but that's just cultural expectations
see this is where it can cause a
disruption in someone's life to the
point where it can become a disorder if
you can't be apart with from each other
for more than 30 minutes you have to
sleep in the same bedroom that makes
accommodations difficult my main concern
is that one would actually die before
the other and the other one would be
lost completely without I mean I'm not
gonna lie I would say that's probably a
little bit of an irrational worry later
in life absolutely you need to start
planning for that but right now as young
women to decide whether or not they need
to learn how to be without each other
shouldn't be based on the fact that one
of them may die that's a fairly lower
risk thing to worry about I've never
heard of them being in a long-term
relationship and that concerns me a lot
that concerns you but what if they don't
want to be in a long-term relationship
that could be totally appropriate so I
set Becky up on a blind date hi Becky
Becky hi and the show obviously tells
them both ways but twins I told Jillian
I would go on this wine day absolutely
and I
it's not exactly how I envisioned it
says they have the same watch I love it
[Music]
we're kind of married to each other yeah
talk about setting up a guy for failure
without giving him a heads up the date
didn't fail because there's something
different about them the date failed
because the guy didn't get a heads up
that they're very unique it's like
setting up someone who doesn't want to
be married on a date and then the person
goes and says do you want to get married
they say no and the data is horribly
could have seen that one
oh
that's a lot of cockroaches you know
what's funny I grew up in Brooklyn and
okay maybe it wasn't that bad but there
were cockroaches in certain areas all
over the place hi my
[Music]
mine I am 9 years old and I collect
cockroaches oh oh wow she kissed
when I started collecting roaches I only
had five you know what I just found out
the other day there are roaches or some
kind of insects that look like roaches
that breathe through their body that
make hissing sounds and it literally
kept me up all night can you imagine
this thing walking next to you and just
going
now I have thousands
oh
I mean roaches don't like bite they may
scratch you accidentally or something
but they don't bite but they do spread
diseases like bacteria especially
salmonella strap staff they can even
cause choleroid dysentery so you got to
be careful with these roaches
um
I could do without them
the father says I could do without them
apart my Madagascar hissing cockroach
I knew some of them his
if they're too noisy I will hiss at him
they're not actually hissy I think
they're breathing they're not harmful at
all except they may be a little stinky
once in a while yeah also you're keeping
like 10 000 of them in like a tupperware
container meant for Legos I don't know
if that's ideal storage for roaches like
why do you need a thousand can you have
one roach one friend roach my name is
Samantha I'm 20 years old I consider
myself pretty responsible independent I
like to have fun and I'm addicted to
tanning oh tanning is so bad I mean
tanning is incredibly problematic
especially as a young person if you're
below the age of 20 and you can't even
want your risk of melanoma goes up like
50 my typical tanning day is going to
three different tanning places 20
minutes in the bed for an equivalence of
an hour a day I think you're almost like
guaranteeing yourself cancer at that
point not only are you increasing
drastically your chances of developing
cancer you're destroying your appearance
because skin becomes dried out becomes
poorer quality looseness occurs tanning
is my everything because it makes me
really happy and you time I'm sad or
upset going tanning just makes me like
perk right up there is some evidence
showing that going tanning a lot and
then stopping can cause like withdrawal
symptoms so we try and help that by
setting the patients or working with
them to go to therapy or even take
medications think about tanning when I
wake up I think about tanning in the
shower I don't think there's actually
over a point where I don't think about
tanning that's worth exploring is she
thinking about how she feels in the
tanning booth is it afterwards is it the
appearance is it something she doesn't
like about herself like all these are
questions that one might ask in a visit
to try and figure out where the source
of thinking about tanning comings comes
from I'm not really worried about the
premature aging because that's why they
have botox plastic surgery faceless the
problem is that doesn't enhance or solve
the problem of what tanning creates like
if the materials themselves AKA your
skin and the the foundational blocks
that make up your skin are damaged
permanently all those things that you
just discussed do not Target or solve
that issue this is a perfect example of
an individual that would benefit from
meeting someone who was also addicted to
tanning and seeing them 10 20 years
later just to get a sense of what can
happen because I think that's that's a
good reality wake-up call from many
you're actually very fortunate I don't
see any signs of skin cancer which is
great but the risk of melanoma is still
huge in someone like you I'm pretty
excited that the doctor didn't find any
skin cancer so now I can go home and
tell people I told you so that's not how
it works when we say it raises your risk
of skin cancer it's not right now it's
across your whole life a lot of young
people have that mindset of oh I don't
even want to live till I'm 40 or 70. I'd
rather get all my fun in now and you
only say that up until you you're 30 or
40 or 50 and then you realize how much
more you want to keep living life and
enjoying the different stages of your
life I am Sydney I am 29 years old and I
am making my neck long what this thing
does is not make your neck long it can
make the appearance of your neck long by
pushing down the clavicles which are
your collar bones here and literally
changing the angle of your top ribs so
it looks like your neck is longer but
it's actually not becoming longer
because of the necklace I had to change
everything in my life even the way I eat
I can feel my throat pressing against
the back of of the necklace when I
swallow if you're limiting your range of
motion you're actually creating
restrictions and blood flow weaknesses
in the stabilizing muscles of the neck
and as a result they're setting yourself
up for future attention headaches
compression headaches maybe even
circulation problems depending on how
tight the neck rings actually are the
idea of stopping stop it has not crossed
my mind because it's been my mind my
whole life look where she's at and look
where I'm at I would love to get my neck
as long as hers remember the way that
the ribs move follow a very specific
pattern to allow maximal expansion of
your lungs and when you're limiting rib
mobility and changing the rib Mobility
you're actually decreasing your ability
to take a full breath and as a result
starting to impact your cardiopulmonary
performance I don't feel very good after
removing the necklace wow it is really
bruised it's a little upsetting to see
the bruising when you have constant
pressure in your skin you could actually
cause pressure necrosis this is
basically what happens in a hospital
when someone stays for a long period of
time and is bed bound can't walk can't
rotate in the bed they could actually
develop pressure ulcers they could get
so deep to the point where the skin gets
broken down all the way to the Bone past
even the the adipose or fat tissue this
is my destiny and this is what I've
chosen for myself people take risks all
the time doing things that they find
valuable and pleasurable and if this
culturally means something to her who
are we to judge I'm Justin jedlika I'm
32 years old and I'm a living doll a
living doll is that a profession is that
a hobby I've had
125 procedures it's a lot of procedures
and it's been a hundred and fifty eight
thousand dollars to make me really
resemble a doll see I wonder if at any
point did his doctors have a discussion
as to why he wants this is it healthy to
keep going for surgical procedures are
there other options like getting in
shape where your muscles can look big
without having to get implants and I'm
only saying that because that's a
healthier alternative not necessarily he
has to do that I started having a couple
other nose revisions I think I'll get a
little fuzzy after a while but at the
end I've had five nose jobs now because
I'm not a plastic surgeon I don't know
what the qualifications are of a person
that should not get plastic surgery but
I think if you're getting multiple
facial revisions and you're doing it to
replicate an imaginary being I think
that's worth an evaluation with a mental
health specialist at the very least
click here for a clip of my interview
with Stevo where he shares his biggest
regret and his most painful injury click
here I promise you won't regret it as
always stay happy and healthy